everybody thought that the idea was
crazy tonight it sincerely did not think
that it was a crazy idea ever wanted to
go to Mars we have been expecting you
people have fantasized what it would be
like for decades Santa Claus you will
never attend now you belong to Mars Oh
some predictions seem pretty silly now
but a Dutch nonprofit called Mars one
says it's serious about a human mission
to the red planet and they want to do it
with billions of dollars drummed up
through media deals and sponsorships and
I literally did not think like I
sincerely did not think that it was a
crazy idea so I thought that that
probably I should apply meat/meat
McCormick she's a filmmaker in Los
Angeles I'm one of the top hundred
finalists for the Mars one mission I
think Mars would be it would be a tough
challenge and it would be actually
somewhat similar to like the explorers
of the new worlds where they went
through harsh winters they didn't have
anything they didn't have anybody to
help the most significant simplification
is that the crew is actually going to
stay and live on Mars with the intention
to remain there for the rest of their
lives if you've been following the news
about Mars one you know that there's
been some criticism of the project does
the Danish nonprofit actually have
enough money to send people to Mars will
the technology be advanced enough for
the mission to take off in the next few
decades to be fair the questions are
really endless when you're trying to
send human beings through space to
another planet where they will
eventually die that's for making me come
to Mars
but for the sake of argument let's just
consider the idea of dying on Mars or
being so dedicated to the cause of
exploration you'd be willing to give up
literally everything here on earth the
trip would probably be the most
stir-crazy that would be because we
wouldn't be able to leave and you'd have
to like work out for three hours a day
and you'd be like right on top of each
other and in case there was like solar
flares or something you'd have to go
like into this chamber that's like
radioactively shielded and you might
have to be there for like two days and
it's tiny but I think once you're
actually there
and everything's set up and good then
there would be plenty of room and you
could go outside in your spacesuit you
could go outside for up to like maybe an
hour a day hike lay mars in the name of
the united states of america it's still
hard to imagine exactly what it would be
like on the planet but fantasizing about
what could be is a necessary part of
exploring the unknown I think a big part
of the mission itself and of the Mars
one program a big reason for it is to
inspire humanity and I think exploration
does that it broadens our horizons it
makes us learn new perspectives and new
ways of thinking about like what we know
what we don't know it has a huge
influence on on ethics beliefs on like
very primal fundamental feelings that we
all have so I think that's important too
so it's like call into question like all
the time and I think that we go through
those points in our lives naturally but
I think that like in the timeline of
humanity I think it's about time for one
of those changes